now a lot of people don't know this but
we have something special tonight okay
the Trump campaign actually granted the
nightly show exclusive backstage access
I'm not making this up I might be making
it up I might be laying it up but I'm
really not making it
okay backstage access to Donald Trump in
the moments leading up to his big speech
and we were able to capture some very
compelling intimate moments take a look
the situation in Turkey is a real mess
and we all know that it was crooked
Hillary's fault but look we got a
restore order okay and we got a minor in
this situation we got to show our
strength we got to get tough like real
tough like unbelievably like I gotta go
all right what the hell happened in
Turkey problems a lot of problems so
many problems in our country folks
believe me whose limbs lose those Obama
Obama black black black Obama mr. Trump
look who's here hey LeBron James you
were absolutely fantastic against the
Warriors my dad you were good I know
under new Middle East advisor
what are you doing oh good
what are you gonna be wearing you later
on tonight oh my god I love that outfit
it's so fantastic there's no sex in it
look I gotta go a bunka so I put that
our hands up doing that the guy behind
me I hear him saying oh I got the wrong
coat so now there's two of us we
obviously on the wrong coat I realize
there's a connection
I look over who do you think I saw
everybody X I can't remember actually
Milania who whose Co was it oh god that
Slovenian accent gets through me
literally like a knife we just fell Ben
it's great wanted a chance it's very
easy unbelievable right that is the
perfect story
unbeliev I don't tell it to most people
most people want to hear it I'll tell it
okay but it's the perfect story I save
it a lot guys guys I just found a
Pikachu of and there's a Jigglypuff look
my remarks about the disabled were taken
out of context okay Jews the Jews Jews I
can't believe the crap that these never
Trump protesters pulled on the
convention floor I mean look I went
every primary I mean I did fantastically
well and now these party hacks wanna
steal my nomination and by the way that
guy from Alaska that delegate he's a
real asshole I was raised in a small
town in southern Indiana in a big family
with a cornfield in the backyard
excuse me excuse me excuse me I didn't
say all of them were rapists I said most
of them I can't do this I can't do it it
was a gag it was fun I was just doing it
for fun I can't do it I get it - let me
out please I gotta get out doing the
final look another contender country I
don't get
unbelievable we'll be right back
you